stan lee was a creator of comics of
plenty did spider-man x-men at your mom
in the 70s okay not really but a legend
yes was he but there was another role
that stan lee had besides writer slash
actor slash maybe your dad and that role
was as a defender of
free speech you see back in the 50s
wasn't cool to be clownish or geeky or
nerdy or quirky or brownish
many found the violence and comic books
unsound
one best-selling author found the comics
concerning moral crusaders took the
comics to burnings and lawmakers on both
sides found some common ground
so the senate held hearings on comic
books that's right the senate held
hearings on comic books with scientific
claims you'd swear came from a commode
so comic book creators across the nation
facing the threat of regulation created
a censoring body they called the comics
code
which takes us back to our hero stand
who was putting out an issue of
spider-man when the comics code folks
said we won't approve
then to know mary marcher's dismay stan
told the code folks
not today and he published it with the
comics code seal removed
now present day we cringe and ride at
the thought of banning books but why why
strong reactions
to an infringe right
well it was each woman was each man who
was brave enough
to take a stand go against the grain and
claim that that ain't right
[Music]
so from all your readers once thought
foolish hypothetical kids who maybe
weren't the coolest we thank you for not
going with plan b
so let's all pause and raise a glass to
the legend who done kicked their ass see
no reason we shouldn't toast to stan lee
stanley stanley
we love you stan
you